I'm almost glad that we lost the money
haha well I'm happy you and your
feelings are so well acquainted but you
wouldn't be the first hostage to fall in
love with their captor lots of laughs
and lots of tissues as one of Canada's
most beloved TV families gets its happy
ending I was both shocked and impressed
well we won't spoil the specifics but
fans of the campy comedy had lots to say
about its final bow making shits finale
the number one trending topic on Twitter
in Canada and the US of course the
series also racked up plenty of famous
fans over the years
apparently Nicole Kidman is a fan of the
show so a handful of a-listers gushed
about the hit series in the post finale
documentary titled best wishes warmest
regards including comedy legend Carol
Burnett who praised Eugene Levy and
Catherine O'Hara's on-screen chemistry I
absolutely have loved them ever since SC
TV so I tuned in you know just to see
what they were up to and I got hooked
Paula Abdul and Will Arnett also popped
up as celeb ambassadors I was just
telling everybody I'd be feeling at my
car yet have you seen since ricans
unbelievable the dock also spotlighted
this show's resonance with the LGBTQ
community and its impact on queer
visibility and acceptance on TV the fact
that people are also experiencing
something deeper through the show is you
can't ask for anything better it's
wonderful and the good vibes don't stop
there I'm a little bit single even when
I'm not
a series of hilarious to Instagram live
broadcasts like Annie Murphy is a little
bit Alexis dance tutorial helped raise
over 180 thousand dollars for food banks
Canada and feeding America ahead of the
series finale thank you